même si les tenues ne sont pas là pour
le prouver les matchs sont on ne peut
plus sérieux six équipes 5 illinois
s'affrontent durant une journée pour la
bonne cause c'est un choix qu'on a fait
dès le départ dès la première édition on
a voulu pas juste faire un tournoi entre
nous mais qui soit aussi pour une bonne
cause et donc chaque année on change de
d'associations qui a un prix du meilleur
déguisement et un prix du meilleur fair
play et puis il ya des animations le
millier aussi qui donne lieu à des
récompenses et là aussi c'est une
occasion de récupérer un des fonds que
l'on que l'on reverra aussi à
l'association après une édition 2010 est
annulée à cause de la crise sanitaire
les organisateurs ont tenu à retrouver
ce moment solidaire avec pour thème
cette année les stations de métro pour
inspirer les déguisements vous avez vu
qu'on a sorti les tenues adéquates parce
que donc notre thème c'était alésia on
n'a plus beaucoup de gaulois mais par
contre on a plein de romain on vient
pour jouer on vient pour jouer la gagne
même si ces tournois loisirs on joue
quand même la gagne et puis il ya
toujours une super ambiance donc c'est
pour ça qu'on revient tous les ans
toujours eu envie de rencontrer les
nouveaux et qui plonge de jouer avec
d'autres personnes las la dre nadine et
alapage moitié assi du loisir a toujours
un peu de compétition après le plus
important d'un évidemment c'est de
prendre du plaisir quoi qu'il arrive
pour cette dixième édition le club sans
syrien a récolté 540 euros ils ont été
remis à l'association un maillot pour la
vie qui s'engagent à redonner sourire et
espoir aux enfants malades autour des
valeurs du sport